what's your views on the recent removal
of
faulty towers german episode
um it's been decades since i've seen it
but if i recall correctly wasn't that
mocking racism
like wasn't that the point i'm not sure
i'm absolutely certain that the
point i i like like it's been decades
since i've watched it but i'm sure the
point of the episode is to mock
some guy who is being racist all the
time and to show him as being the
backwards buffoon that he clearly was
um but yeah nothing nothing safe and you
know what's interesting is who asked for
it
who asked for them to take these things
down you know
this is this is the very interesting
germans don't strike me as the sort of
group that are vetting i don't know what
i don't know the german culture that
closely but they don't strike me as the
sort of social justice type
uh there's probably a bit more social
justice in there than you think
really um oh yeah i lived in germany for
eight years like
they're they're quite systematic
thinkers um but it wasn't germans that
got it pulled it wasn't even because of
germans
uh it was because the guy said the
n-word in it um
because in the seven yeah yeah yeah yeah
made in the 70s
so i don't remember that happening i'm
sure i'm i think i'm sure he did i'm
sure he did i like his
comments below yeah yeah it's been
decades since i've seen him i'm sure he
says the n-word in it
but that's part of the ridiculousness of
the character you know that's part of
what you're meant to be laughing at
um but yeah it wasn't it wasn't german's
got to pull down but it was go it was
people who were
un aware that the mob on twitter
has certain trigger points and one of
those is
the n-word the other one is blackface
you know
so a bunch of things were taken down
that had people doing blackface and
again
the joke is not the expense of black
people it's the expense of the character
doing the blackface but it doesn't
matter the context is all gone now
that masks both selector was shite when
it came out
yes like that should have been taken
down for just being
[ __ ] like forget forget the implications
of socialism that's whiteness that's
white meritocratic view isn't it well
avid marion was just
wank like regardless i never liked that
a man like how dare you how dare you
make your career off the back of craig
david
who it must have murdered and i know for
a fact
that he's had a conversation with lee
what's he called the fellow the avid
marion guy the guy that's like three
layers behind the person that was
yeah craig david that guy um and uh
then craig had this amazing resurgence
of a career like what sort of four or
five years ago something like that did
that song and then justin bieber remix
and blah blah
and now he's selling out ibiza doing all
this stuff but his career
make no mistake about his career stopped
because
of that character yeah that's why his
career tanked
like forget the social justice side of
stuff
that's one man bearing the brunt he's
the tip of
a very very very long spear right
and he's bearing the brunt of all of
that like that is [ __ ] disgusting
that's the thing that's terrible
about it like think about all the jokes
that craig davids had to go through i
had this flourishing career this young
uh mixed race r b artist fantastic good
looking guy really good voice blah blah
blah
and then just some fella decides again
regardless of race could have been a
black guy could have been a white guy
could be an asian guy
decides to do that like that's
absolutely scandalous but that was
allowed on tv at the time
how do you get something passed that is
targeting
one person well that that was why john
barnes said he
saw no problem with it at all it was
making fun of a particular person he
wasn't making fun of a race or anything
but again now with with this new
framework
of the idea of whiteness uh there's no
such thing
like everything that we do is inherently
racial
uh to these people so uh no none of that
sort of stuff is gonna be made anymore
you know so
this is over now yeah is this just the
new world because i'm being honest like
again i don't want my empathy is sort of
fairly crippling and i don't want
something to be on tv that makes a group
of people feel uncomfortable
like if if it was uh if that was the
sort of thing that really does make a
big swath of the
population feel uncomfortable then like
have it for people that should have it
on dvd
or whatever you know the same way as
sacrilegious books or whatever back in
the game
don't burn the books but in the same way
facebook doesn't put pornography on
curate the message for the audience and
don't put it in front of people who may
not want to see it
i'm sure is this the new world now have
we permanently brought the guard rails
in on the type of content that's going
to be produced publicly
um yes until there's a counter
revolution
uh the the the social justice types are
revolutionaries openly so they'll tell
you i mean bernie sanders
has been leading this and he's been
calling it a revolution he
wrote a book called our revolution you
know
i mean he's not nearly down as far down
the rabbit hole as these people but
he's still part of the same movement um
and they they're very
they love communist revolutions because
the idea is there's gonna be an amazing
revolution
we'll establish the perfect order and
therefore history's over we can carry on
living as however we we choose
um the essentially there's gonna like
and it looks like all of our
institutions have fallen to this it
looks like every company because
there's no solid defense against it
because
essentially you would have to make a
defense outside of the logic of the
thing and nobody seems to be prepared to
do this
like every every conservative should be
standing saying look
i'm not making a commentary on black
lives matter
as in as much as i am objecting to the
moral framework
that black lives matter is built on you
know i don't believe in racial
collectivization
i don't believe that we should tear down
some because of the others and i don't
believe
that we can ignore bad actions for good
intent
you know the actions matter we're like i
say we
but generally like i guess what we'll
just call the right wing is very
procedural you know how
you get to where you are the the means
are what justify the ends
and they really are on the other side
the ends justify the means this is why
they don't care
if they're burning down cities like
thousands of
businesses have been burned and looted
in america in the past month
thousands it's crazy in 40 cities
there's a part of a city that's been
taken over by communists
and i'm just like there's just
no not one thing burned or looted is
justified you know but
to the people who are supporting it and
this is everywhere this is newspapers
this is left-wing politicians this is
corporations
so the people supporting it they don't
care you know they don't care about the
damage that's been done
and that's that's the the the schism at
the heart of the whole thing
and then while this order is in place
it's going to act exactly as you would
think it's going to drive towards moral
perfection like this abstract moral
perfection
you you can already say now who was it
someone someone who did
blackface uh in a comedy skit like 10
years ago
i can't remember which one it was one of
the late night comedians
someone like that yeah someone like that
wasn't him but it was something like
that
they they were saying they were taking
like a year off or something
it's like oh really at the time when the
blackface video resurfaces
exactly so i mean exactly i don't really
the thing the thing is this order is
going to continue and it's going to
continue establishing itself until
essentially it becomes untenable but
this
this group of people on the other side
who think well actually we think that a
plurality of views and
behavior matters um until they
conduct their own kind of
counter-revolution and either not
just take back the industries or create
new ones
um then it's going to be the social
justice regime from here now and you can
see
on the on twitter at the moment the
things going around at the sky
sky cinema whether like this
this uh like i can't remember exactly
how it is but essentially this film was
made in a different era
and may contain scenes that are
disturbing to other people and it's
based
you know it's for everything even like
the 2019 aladdin reboot
is now problematic quickly making
pejorative statements about people from
arabia
i don't even think it is like i watched
it i don't i didn't see
anything curly toe shoes with the little
bells on the end or anything like that
but that's not is that bad well i don't
know this is the thing
right the meaning but i don't know i
don't know i don't i don't know so
[Music]